Let's create a route where we can view
the details of each of our menu items.
Remember that all of the items
share the item template.
Let's generate the item route.
This updates the router, creates an item
route and template file and a test file.
Remember that this is just shorthand for
this.
To add a dynamic segment for
this route, we need to modify the path.
Remember that dynamic segments
have to start with a colon.
This will hold the name
of the menu item.
Let's add something to the item template
so we'll have something to see.
I'm hard coding in a menu item's name,
image, rating, and description.
We need some way to get to
the item page from the menu, so
let's add a link to each item.
Now we can get to an item's detail page.
Right now though we've hard coded this
menu item into the item template.
So even if I try to view the strawberry
pudding, I'll still get the ham and
goat cheese croissant.
We'll fix this in a bit.